Parents, families, friends,
welcome to the 309th commencement
of Yale University.
We gather to recognize the extraordinary accomplishments
of all you who have worked so hard
to complete your programs of study.
We salute your effort,
your diligence,
your talent, and your intellect.
We also join you in expressing gratitude for
all who have supported you in these endeavors:
your families,
friends, teachers,
and other members of the Yale community.
In keeping with the tradition of this occasion,
I now call upon the chaplain
to offer an invocation.
My sisters and my brothers,
let us pray.
Almighty God,
source of all truth,
here we stand in the splendor of
this morning, many expressions of one living mystery,
which is beyond all telling.
As students of your handiwork,
we have gathered from all parts of your world
with exquisite ambitions
and have been blessed at this place of truth
and light
with the freedom to let them grow.
You walk with us when we stumble
and when we sore.
As we pause here, embraced by this moment,
we are grateful for our beloved families and
friends,
yet we are mindful of the dear ones
who are not here and they are deeply missed.
Our God of all generations,
you are the guardian
of where we are going
and who we are becoming.
You have called us to lovingly shape this beautiful yet aching world.
We are humbled,
but ready.
Now we ask you,
bless our hands with tenderness for all that we touch,
bless our lips with wise words so we speak in healing ways,
bless our eyes with an impassioned vision
so we are never blind to
possibility, and bless our hearing
so we may be open to all understanding.
From this moment on,
infuse our hearts with an imaginative daring,
one that stirs us to become
living,
vibrant examples
of
shalom, of salaam,
of shanti,
of peace.
For this we say.
amen.
Mr. President,
I have the honor to present candidates for
the bachelor's degrees in Yale College.
For the degree of bachelor of arts,
one thousand forty seven in number
and for the degree of bachelor of science,
two hundred and thirty two in number.
They have been recommended
by the faculty of Yale College
and approved by the corporation.
I now ask you,
by your official act,
to confer upon them
these degrees.
By the authority vested in me, I confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in Yale College,
as designated by the dean,
and admit you to all their rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President,
I have the honor to announce the winner of
prizes in Yale College,
which were confirmed at Class Day exercises yesterday.
The Louis Sudler Prize
for excellence in the arts is awarded this
year
to Lucy Hazel Fitz Gibbon
of Timothy Dwight College.
The Warren Memorial High Scholarship Prize is awarded to the senior majoring in the humanities,
who ranks highest in
scholarship. The Arthur Twining Hadly Prize is awarded to the senior in Yale College
majoring in the social sciences,
who ranks highest in
scholarship. This year both prizes are awarded to Mihan Robin Lee of
Saber College.
The Russell, the Russell
Henry Chittenden Prize is awarded to that senior
in Yale College majoring in the natural sciences or in mathematics, who
ranks highest in scholarship.
This year's prize is awarded to Susan Elizabeth
Scanlon of Timothy Dwight College.
And the Alpheus Henry Snow Prize is awarded to that senior
who through the combination of intellectual achievement,
character, and personality shall be adjudged
by the faculty to have done the most for Yale
by inspiring in his or her classmates an admiration and love
for the best traditions of high scholarship.
This year
the Snow Prize is awarded to Elias S. Bildner
of Davenport College.
I congratulate you for the extraordinary achievement,
which is represented by these awards.
For the contribution that you have made to
you, to your university,
and for the promise
which your accomplishments hold,
for the life and times of your generation,
congratulations.
Mr. President
I have the honor
to present candidates
for degrees in the School of Architecture.
Small,
but noticeable.
For the degree of master of architecture,
sixty-five in number.
For the degree of master of environmental
design,
four in number.
They have been recommended,
they have been recommended by the faculty
of the school
and approved by the corporation.
I now ask you,
by your official act,
to confer upon them these degrees.
By the authority vested in me, I confer
upon you
the degrees in architecture
and design as designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President, I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the School of Art.
For the degree of master of fine arts, fifty-four in number.
They have been recommended by the faculty of the
School of Art and approved by the corporation.
I now ask you, by your official act, to confer
upon them this degree.
By the authority invested in me, I confer upon you
the degree in art as designated by the dean and admit you to all its rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President, I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the School of Drama.
For the degree of master of fine arts,
fifty-seven in number
and for the degree of doctor of fine arts,
one in number.
They have been recommended by the faculty
of the school and approved by the corporation.
I now ask you, by your official act, to confer
upon them these degrees.
By the authority vested in me, I confer upon you the degrees in drama
designated
0:11:39.609,0:11:46.609
by the dean and admit you to all their rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President,
I have the honor to present candidates for
degrees in the School of Music.
For the certificate in performance, three in number.
For the artist diploma,
twenty five in number.
For the degree master of music, seventy-nine in number.
For the degree master of musical arts,
six in number
and for the degree doctor of musical arts,
six in number. They have been recommended by the faculty
of the school and approved by the corporation.
I now ask you, by your official act, to
confer upon them these degrees.
By the authority vested in me, I confer upon you the degrees in music
as designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President,
I have the honor to present candidates for degrees in the School of Nursing.
For the certificate in nursing,
seventy-nine in number.
For the
post-master's certificate in nursing,
two in number. For the degree of master of science in nursing,
one hundred and eight in number.
And for the degree of doctor of nursing science,
two in number.
They have been recommended by the faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation.
I now ask you, by your official act, to confer upon them these degrees.
By the authority vested in me, I confer upon you the degrees in nursing as
designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President,
I have the honor to present candidates for
degrees in the School of Forestry and Environmental
Studies.
For the degree,
for the degree of master of forestry,
twelve in number.
For the degree of master of forest science, seven in
number.
For the degree of master of environmental
management,
seventy-six in number.
For the degree of master of environmental science
forty in number.
They have been recommended by the faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation.
I now ask you,
by your official act,
to confer upon them these degrees.
By the authority vested in me, I confer upon
you the degrees in forestry and environmental
studies
as designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President,
I have the honor to present candidates what
degree in the School of Management.
For the degree,
for the degree of master's of business administration, two hundred and seven in number.
They have been recommended by the faculty
of the school and approved by the corporation.
I now ask
you, by your official act, to confer upon them this degree.
By the authority vested in me, I confer upon
you the degree in management as designated
by the dean
and admit you to all its rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President,
I have the honor to present candidates for
that degrees in the Divinity School.
For the degree of master of arts in religion, sixty-nine in number.
For the degree of master of divinity, fifty-one in number.
And for the degree of master of sacred theology,
twelve it number.
They have been recommended by the faculty of the school and approved by the corporation.
I now ask you, by your official act, to confer
upon them these degrees.
By the authority vested in me, I confer upon
you the degrees in religion, divinity, and
theology as designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President, I have the honor to present candidates for degrees in the Law School.
For the degree
of master of studies in law, one in number.
For degree of juris doctor,
one hundred and ninety-six in number.
For the degree of master of laws,
twenty-three in number.
For the degree
of the doctor of the science of law,
two in number.
When they have been recommended by the faculty
of the school and approved by the corporation
I shall ask you, by your official act,
to confer upon them
their degrees.
By the authority vested in me,
I shall confer upon you
the degrees in the Law School when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities.
Mr. President,
I have the honor to present candidates for degrees in the Graduate School.
For the degree
of master of science,
one hundred fifty-one in number.
For the degree of master of arts,
two hundred eighty-seven in number.
For the degree of master of philosophy,
three hundred nineteen in number.
They have been recommended by the faculty
of the school and approved by the corporation.
I now ask you, by your official act,
to confer upon them these degrees.
By the authority vested in me I confer upon
you the degrees in the Graduate School as designated
by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President, I have the honor to present
candidates
for degrees in the School of Public Health.
For the degree of master of public health, a hundred and eight in number.
They, they have been recommended by the faculty and
approved by the corporation. I now ask you, by your official act, to grant
upon them these degrees.
By the authority vested in me, I confer upon
you the degree in public health as designated
by the dean
and admit you to all its rights and responsibilities.
Mr. President,
I have the honor
to present candidates for degrees in the
School of Medicine.
For the degree
of master of medical science, thirty-six in
number.
When they have been recommended by the faculty
of the school
and approved by the corporation,
I shall ask you, by your official act,
to confer upon them this degree.
For the degree of master of health science,
twenty-three in number.
And, and for the degree of doctor of medicine, one
hundred and nine in number.
The, they have been recommended by the faculty
at the school
and approved by the cooperation.
I now ask you, by your official act,
to confer upon and these degrees.
By the authority vested in me,
I shall confer the degree in medical science
and do confer
upon you the degrees in health science and medicine
as designated by the dean and admit you to
all the rights and responsibilities.
There's more.
Please be seated.
We now proceed to the awarding of honorary
degrees.
The ten men and women we honor this morning
serve as examples to your our graduates,
to encourage you to aspire to excellence,
to value those elements of human character
that they embody:
creativity,
curiosity,
discipline,
integrity,
and a passion for social justice.
Their presence here also honors you who
graduate today
and all of us who are here to salute you.
I will now, as is customary, call upon the provost
to present
the candidates
for honorary degrees.
Mr. President,
I have the honor
to present the candidates for honorary degrees.
For the degree of doctor of humanities,
Robert Alter,
scholar.
As a scholar of comparative literature,
your thoughtful and brilliant work
ranges from
studies of the English and European novel
to questions of tradition and modernity to
trends in American and Jewish culture,
but the greatest gifts you have given us are
your unparalleled translation and your interpretations
of the Hebrew Bible.
By combining a poetic ear
with intellectual rigor
you have illuminating, illuminated been the meaning
of these ancient sacred texts in a fresh voice
that is faithful to their origins.
Celebrating the beauty and inspiration of
your work,
we're pleased to convert the degree
of doctor of humanities.
For the degree of doctor of laws,
Ellen Johnson Sirleaf,
president of the Republic of Liberia.
As an advocate for reform and as the first
woman elected as head of state in an African
country,
you are an inspiration.
Arrested for challenging the ruling powers
you persevered to run for office, fight corruption,
and bring integrity to government.
Popular with your people and principled in
your politics,
you have promoted economic development, improved
health,
restored civility,
and kept peace.
Your vision of a renewed Liberia is becoming
a reality
because of your sacrifice,
dedication,
determination,
and wisdom.
We are greatly honored to bestow upon you
the degree
of doctor of law.
For the degree of doctor of medical sciences,
Michael Rutter, child psychiatrist.
Widely acclaimed as the father of child psychiatry,
your pioneering work
has powerfully advanced our understanding of
the mental health,
social development,
and resilience of children and adolescents.
Your seminal studies of the effects of disrupted
maternal interaction
and the emotional mechanisms for coping with
stress
have transformed the way we view child development.
You've taken children seriously,
examining behavior through the complex interaction
of environment,
interpersonal relationships,
genes, neuro-biology, and schooling.
For your intellectual curiosity,
your ground-breaking research, and your contributions
to the well-being of children,
we are proud to name you
doctor of medical science.
For the degree
of doctor of humane letters,
Michael Feinberg and David Levin, educators.
You are educational entrepreneurs
and visionaries.
Your creation,
the Knowledge is Power program,
has helped poor children achieve impressive academic success.
With more than eighty KIP schools now serving over 21, 000 students in
nineteen states,
you are showing how classrooms can be transformed
and how the promise of public education
can be fulfilled.
You  practice
what you teach _
"Work hard,
be nice."
We are  pleased to award you, Michael, your first
Yale degree,
and to welcome you home, David, for a second
one,
doctor a humane letters.
For the degree of doctor of fine arts,
Zhang Yimou,
filmmaker and choreographer.
A genius with camera and choreography,
your work
has portrayed China in all its glory, complexity,
contradiction, and charm.
In films that explore triumph and oppression,
history and hope,
you have captured the struggles of the human
spirit
and engaged and enlightened audiences
around the globe.
From film to opera to live performance,
you're artistry amazes and entertains.
The dazzling opening ceremony of the Beijing
Olympic games,
you're epic salute to Chinese history and
culture,
endures vividly in our memory.
we are delighted to bestow on you this degree
of doctor of fine arts.
For the degree of doctor of social sciences,
Marilyn Strathern,
anthropologist.
Your research has had a seminal influence
on the field of social anthropology.
From your studies of gender in Melanesia
to your work on kinship in England,
you have made fundamental substantive and methodological advances.
You are an intellectual's intellectual, admired
by your students,
respected by your colleagues.
You are a teacher of uncompromising standards
and as the head of Girton college, an exemplary
citizen of Cambridge University.
For your contributions,
to our understanding of the human family,
we name you doctor of social sciences.
For the degree
of doctor of letters,
Orhan Pamuk, novelist.
You have helped
to give new life to the novel,
one that weaves together past and present,
modernity and history,
national and cosmopolitan,
secular and religious.
Your stories are rich and multi-layered,
complex and at times mystical.
You're writing bridges the themes of east
and west,
tackling
issues and moral questions
faced by thoughtful people in Turkey and
around the globe.
The world has honored you with countless devoted readers.
and a nobel prize.
We add our acclaim with the degree of doctor of letters.
For the degree of doctor of music.
Aretha Franklin, vocalist.
We know royalty when we see it
and you are without question
the queen of soul.
A natural woman,
you have been singing your whole life,
learning the grace of gospel from family and faith community,
tuning it with your own
sometimes painful, often joyful experience
and creating a signature style
0:38:59.529,0:39:02.499.
that transcends any one musical genre
You have some the nation's hopes at presidential
inaugurations
and shared your gifts
with generations of music lovers.
From gospel to pop,
from blues to hip-hop,
your voice expresses our feelings.
With the greatest
R E S P E C T,
we name you doctor of music.
For the degree
of doctor of science,
Steven Chu, scientist and public servant.
As an experimental physicist, you accomplished
the seemingly impossible
but trapping and cooling atoms with beams
of light.
Now
you are confronting
another
formidable challenge,
transforming national energy policy.
You are promoting new technologies that will
reduce our dependence on foreign oil and even
more significantly,
overcome the dangers
of global warming.
As a community of scholars, we take immense
pride
that a nobel laureate and physicist is serving
the nation at such a critical time
and we're delighted to honor you
with the degree of doctor of science.
Let us pray. May the gracious one who has brought us to this joyous and glorious day
guard us and guide us, as we
go forth, inspiring us to turn our learning
into lives dedicated to the service of
truth and goodness,
of light and peace,
and of justice for all. Amen.